[Music]
Khloe Kardashian Jessica Simpson and
more stars celebrate Mother's Day I'm
being honored for something that I love
doing most in life and that is being a
mother Jessica Simpson indulged in sugar
while celebrating Mother's Day on Sunday
sharing a pic of the yummy donuts her
daughter Maxwell and son ace gifted her
captioning the pic my kiddos know the
way to mommy's heart Khloe Kardashian
was showered with beautiful flowers on
her first Mother's Day just one day
before the Keeping Up star posted her
first adorable video of baby true to
social media happy one-month old momma I
love you pretty girl Khloe's sister Kim
somehow managed to snag a pic with all
three of her kids letting fans know it
wasn't an easy feat quote you don't even
understand how many lollipop bribes this
pic cost me I'm luckiest mom in the
world to have these three babies in my
life it was really tough for me
[Music]
Jersey Shore family vacation star Ronnie
ortiz-magro surprisingly celebrated with
his ex-girlfriend and baby mama Jen
Harley posting sweet videos to his
Instagram story of his daughter sleeping
on Jen's chest
[Music]
Justin Bieber and ariana grande
celebrated their mommas with two cute
photos happy Mother's Day to pepper to
my mom while John Legend has celebrated
the special women in his life and his
daughter Luna with wife Chrissy Teigen
dressed up for the occasion as an
adorable Tinkerbell
the all of me singer also shared this
sweet snap with his budding family
gushing in the caption happy Mother's
Day to my wonderful wife Chrissy I can't
wait to meet our little boy
[Music]
[Applause]